okay so we've been spending a lot of
time looking at this controllability
matrix of this system this linear system
X dot equals ax plus bu we know some
things about this so we know that for
example in MATLAB if I look at the rank
of this controllability matrix rank of
CT RB of a a comma B if this is rank n
so CT RB just gives me this matrix if
the rank of this is n the dimension of
my state space then the system is
controllable which is great okay but
that is a binary condition that is a yes
or a No it is controllable completely or
it's not controllable and we don't know
in what way it's not controllable this
is purely a binary rank condition but in
practice there are much richer and more
useful measures of controllability
so how controllable are different
directions in RN and we can get those by
looking at things like the singular
value decomposition of this matrix or
something called the controllability
gram ian ok so I'm going to write down a
few things that we're going to relate so
first of all we know that the solution
of the system X dot equals ax if we just
had an initial condition we would have X
of T equals e to the matrix a T times X
at time 0 ok so in the absence of
control then we would just have this
either the a T times the initial
condition and now in the absence of an
initial condition if we just had control
we would also get this plus integral
from 0 to t e to the a t minus tau times
B U of tau D tau ok and for those of you
who have dealt with impulse responses
and linear systems before you'll
recognize that this is the convolution
of e to the a T with our input u so
essentially this e to the a T is kind of
a kernel
and we're sliding our control and put
you across that colonel and convolving
but well we'll get into that later on
when we talk about the equivalence of
state space differential equations with
impulse response convolution
representations and transfer functions
so that's down the road we'll talk about
the convolution interpretation but I
just want you to know that there is an
expression for the solution X of T that
solve this and it's essentially the
convolution integral of e to the a T
with u tau with UT ok and there's
something really really important called
the controllability Graham Ian okay so
the controllability Graham in and I hope
I'm not misspelling this there's also
something called the observability
Graham in when we start doing
measurements but we'll do deal with that
later so the controllability granion is
this object WT equals integral from 0 to
t sometimes this is from 0 to infinity e
to the a tau B times B I'm going to say
transpose sometimes people do complex
conjugate transpose but I'm going to
start with real valued A's and B's if
these were complex this would be a star
times e to the a transpose tau D tau ok
so this is the time T granion oftentimes
we we take T goes to infinity and we
look at the infinite time granion but
for now let's just look at this object
and something I think is really
important so this is a lesson I was
taught early on is you should always
think when you're working with a
mathematical object you should always
think to yourself what am i and where do
I live ok so this is the controllability
Graham Ian and it lives in are n by n
this is an N by n matrix ok so this is
easy to verify each of the a T is an N
by n square matrix BB transpose so if I
have this like column vector column
vectors in B
and I multiply it by column vectors and
B transpose the outer dimensions are
both n so I get an N by n square matrix
and then e to the a transpose T is also
an N by n square matrix so long story
short this granion is an N by n matrix
and because it's in this case real
valued and symmetric we know that it's
going to have positive real eigenvalues
and so I look at the eigen decomposition
of this object if I look at WT P equals
lambda C then essentially I have I can
list I can order these eigen values of
this granion from biggest eigen value
down to smallest eigen value they're all
non-negative so there's a biggest one
down to a smallest one and the
eigenvectors corresponding to the
biggest eigen values are the most
controllable directions in state space
let me say that again the eigenvectors
of this granion court that had the
biggest eigenvalue are the most
controllable directions in state space
meaning i can go farther in those
directions on the same amount of input
energy or let's say i'll say that this
is a gallon of I have a gallon of gas of
input energy I can go farther in the
directions with bigger lambda than I can
in the directions with smaller lambda
this is really cool okay and so in lots
of circumstances I haven't told you why
that's true or how you would compute
this for discrete-time systems
oftentimes this is approximately equal
to this controllability matrix times the
controllability matrix transpose so
that's also an N by n matrix you can
verify or like this impulse response
matrix where I kick the system and I
measure it for a long time this is
almost equal to this and I'm going to
we're going to have a whole lecture on
this down the road where we talk about
these empirical graeme ins that we
measure from impulse response data and
we're going to talk about these
eigenvectors in much much more detail
I'm just giving you the high-level
overview
but you'll notice that the eigenvalues
and eigenvectors of this matrix are the
singular vectors and singular values of
C so what I could do is I could look at
you Sigma V equals FV D of this
controllability matrix and in practice
I'm going to say I want the economy SVD
okay so in that lab this is literally
what I would type in I would type in the
SVD of this controllability matrix and
what I'm going to get so now the biggest
eigen values here are my singular values
squared I think okay so I still get this
hierarchy now of singular values in this
diagonal matrix Sigma and then the eigen
vectors C are my left singular vectors
they're the columns of U and so now this
is really really cool instead of just a
binary yes-or-no my system is
controllable now I actually get an
ordered list of directions that are most
controllable so the first column of U is
the most controllable direction the
second column is the second most
controllable direction all the way down
to the least controllable direction this
is just simple matrix algebra in that
lab it's one line and then what you can
do is essentially take these these
controllable directions and what they
define is some energy ellipsoid so this
is really neat I want to just draw I'm
going to draw this an R 3 but you'll get
the idea so what I can do is draw this
energy ellipsoid in R 3 where
essentially my most controllable
direction so let's say I go in the c1
direction so this is C 1 lambda 1 or
Sigma 1 whatever you want to call it I
can go farther
so this ellipsoid the ax use the
principal axes of this are my singular
vectors of this controllability matrix
so this is
lambda1 key one this might be this might
be lambda 2 C 2 and this one might be
lambda 3 C 3 and what this means is that
for a unit of input energy let's say
I've got 1 gallon of gas I've got 1 unit
of energy I can input so if I norm U of
T and it equals 1 this is literally how
this is the surface of how far I can go
in any direction so I can steer my
system around but I can steer it farther
if I go just in the C one direction I
can steer it less far in the C 2
direction and I can I can drive it the
least far in the C 3 direction and if I
go in some combination I'm going to land
at that point on this ellipsoid so if I
go in some direction here I'm going to
hit I'm going to run out of gas at that
point so this is incredibly physical and
intuitive okay so if controllability is
not just a yes or a no decision there
are degrees of controllability and
they're different in different
directions of my state space and all of
us know this if you're driving a car
it's easy to go forward right the wheels
are aligned forward I can go forward
really easily it's hard to kind of
parallel park okay so parallel parking
is harder to do than going forward and
in lots of control systems some
directions are easy to go in and others
are harder to go in and you find those
directions by taking the singular value
decomposition of your controllability
matrix Eclipse so this is the easy way
to do it in MATLAB mathematically those
are the eigenvectors of this
controllability grammy in we haven't
really talked about what this is yet but
this is a very very physically motivated
quantity so the eigenvectors have
meaning in fact they have exactly this
meaning that they tell you how far you
can go on a unit normed input you okay
extremely useful and also extremely easy
to compute in MATLAB good
so one last thing I want to I want to
get to and I think we're kind of just
very gradually working up to this is X
might be a vector in a very high
dimensional state space so this might be
a million dimensional state space
describing the fluid flow over you know
a Boeing jet wing or something like that
so this could be an extremely
complicated state of all of the fluid
velocities at a million locations this
could be some linearization for example
about some laminator laminar boundary
layer profile and the idea here is it is
too much to ask necessarily for all of
our end to be controllable so for
example in that in that fluid example
let's say I have I've got you know flow
past my wings and let's say that it's
doing something it's got some dynamics
right maybe it's doing a little vortex
shedding so controllability in all of
our n means that I have I can control my
system so that I can control the
vorticity here or here or here and to
some extent I don't need full RN
controllability I just need to be able
to control the things that I'm likely to
see in my system the the coherent
structures that if I if I just measure
my system what would be in the data okay
what would exist in my data what impacts
lift and drag or my control objective
okay and so the idea here is many many
many directions in RN are extremely
stable so if I have a big disturbance
here like a really big vortex or some
some disturbance what's probably going
to happen is that that's going to die
out really quickly it's going to get
like blended in to this dominant pattern
so there's going to be some very very
stable directions here that I don't care
about so oftentimes what we really care
about is something called stabilized
ability and I'm doubting I'm going to
spell this one right but a system is
stabilizable
if all of its unstable directions are
controllable so if I look at this
controllable subspace given by the
singular vectors of this matrix I want
all of my unstable directions all of the
unstable eigenvectors of a so it's
stabilizable its stabilizable if and
only if all unstable eigenvectors of a
are in my controllable subspace meaning
are in the column space of this
controllability matrix if all of my
unstable eigenvectors of a are in this
controllable subspace that i'm
stabilizable okay so I might not be able
to control all of our n but everything
that's unstable I can control and I this
is the normal definition but I think a
much more useful definition is that if
all unstable and lightly damped so it
doesn't strictly speaking have to be
just unstable if there's something
that's kind of marginally stable or
barely stable I also want that to be in
my controllable subspace so that I can
make it more stable okay so in really
high dimensional systems again we're
looking at degrees of controllability
and we're looking at degrees of
controllability in special directions in
RN so there is an unstable eigenvector
of a or a very lightly damped you know
an eigenvector with a lightly damped
eigenvalue I really want that to be
highly controllable so I want to choose
my actuators B so that the unstable
dynamic directions correspond to big
singular vectors of this controllability
matrix okay again we'll talk more about
this later we'll talk about this in the
context of model reduction of how we
take this million dimensional system and
get a low-order model that we can use
for real time control but that's all
going to come later okay thank you